We've been looking at Plato's arguments for the immortality of the soul and so
forth.
So far I have to say I haven't found them very compelling arguments.
In a minute I'm going to turn to an argument that at least strikes me as more
interesting.
It's more difficult to pin down where it goes wrong.
But before we do,
I want to make the last couple of comments about the argument we were
considering at the end of last class.
That was the argument from recollection.
You recall,
the basic idea was that although objects in the ordinary,
familiar empirical world are not perfectly just perfectly round what have you,
they're able to remind us of perfect justice,
perfect roundness and the like.
And when Plato asked himself,
how could that be the answer he gives us?
Well,
it's gotta be that we were previously acquainted with the forms before our life
in this world,
and that shows that the soul must be something that existed prior to the
creation of the body.
That's the argument from recollection and what at the very end of class I
suggested that look,
even if we were to grant to Plato,
that in order to think about justice,
circularity,
what have you,
we had to somehow grasp the forms and even if we were to grant to Plato that
nothing in this world is perfectly round or perfectly just,
it's not necessarily correct to say so.
The only possible explanation of what's going on is that these things in the
empirical world remind us of our prior acquaintance with the forms.
It couldn't be that what goes on is when we bumped up against something that's
partially just or partially beautiful or partially round in perfectly round,
what happens is those things sort of trigger our minds in such a way that we
begin to think about the forms for the very first time.
So it might be in order to think about justice and roundness,
we have to grasp the forms,
but it couldn't be that we only grasp the forms in this life for the very first
time.
Exposure to the things that participate in the forms may nudge our minds or our
souls in such a way that at that point,
given that exposure,
we begin to grasp the forms.
It's as though the,
the ordinary earthly objects we bump into them or they bump into us and they get
us to look upwards to the heavenly platonic realm.
I don't mean literally upwards.
It's not as though these things and the number three is up there,
but if you accept the metaphor sort of running into things in the empirical
world,
get our minds to start thinking about for the first time the heavenly realm of
the platonic forms and ideas that would be just as likely a possibility as the
alternative explanation that what's going on is the ordinary empirical objects
are reminding of us,
reminding us of our prior acquaintance.
Perhaps these ordinary objects act like letters of introduction,
getting us to,
helping us to think about the forms for the very first time.
Well,
if that's right,
then of course we don't have any good reason to follow Plato when he says it
must be the case that the soul existed prior to the prior to birth.
Now the objection I've just raised is not an objection that Plato raises in the
Fito,
but he does raise a different objection.
Remember,
our concern isn't strictly speaking with the question,
did the soul exists before our birth?
Did the soul exists before our bodies but rather is the sole immortal?
And so having now given the argument from recollection,
Plato envisions two of Socrates disciples,
Sindhis and cvs responding objecting by saying,
look,
even if the sole existed before birth,
it doesn't follow that it exists after death and that's after all what we really
want are wondering about,
we want to know will we survive our deaths is the sole immortal and you haven't
yet shown that Socrates they object could be that it existed before but won't
exist afterwards,
but very nicely.
It's quite elegant structure at this point.
Socrates puts together the two arguments that we've just been rehearsing the
argument from recollection and the argument that came before that.
The one that I dubbed the argument from recycling.
I remember the argument from recycling says when when you build something,
you build it out of parts and when that thing falls apart you go back to the
parts.
Okay.
All right.
So the prior parts get recycled.
This soul,
we now say based on the argument from recollection,
the soul is one of our prior parts.
You know the sole existed before we were put together before we were put
together with our bodies.
If you then combine the argument from recycling and say the parts that existed
before are going to exist to afterwards,
it must follow that if the sole existed before,
it will exist afterwards at all afterwards as well.
So we've got the immortality of the soul after all.
Now
bracket the fact that as I just explained,
I don't myself find the argument from recollection persuasive.
I don't think we've got any good reason believe based on the sort of things that
play those drawing our attention to.
I don't think we've got any good reason to believe that the soul existed before
we were born.
Okay.
But even if we grant him that we shouldn't be so quick to conclude on the basis
of combining the argument from recollection and the argument from recycling that
the soul will continue to exist after the death of our bodies after all,
take take a more familiar humdrum example.
Um,
cars are built out of non cars,
right?
Cars get built out of engines and tires and steering wheels and you know,
the engine's not a car,
the steering wheel's not a car.
So you build the car out of its parts.
Now the engine's a prior existing part.
So can we conclude then that from the fact that sort of argument from recycling
parts get reused,
get rebuilt when cars get destroyed,
it's parts are still around.
Can we conclude from the argument from recycling and the fact that the engine is
a prior existing part from which the car was built,
that the engine will continue to exist forever after the destruction of the car?
No.
Obviously you can't conclude that at all.
Sometimes when cars get destroyed,
the engine gets destroyed right along with it.
And of course,
even if in many cases the engine continues to exist for a while after the
destruction of the car,
it certainly doesn't follow that the engine is immortal,
that it continues to exist forever.
Engines will eventually decompose and turn back into Adam's.
So from the mere fact that the engine was a part that existed before the car
existed,
and the further fact that when the car breaks down,
sort of,
it decomposes back into parts,
it certainly doesn't follow that all of the parts that existed prior to the
existence of the car will be around forever.
That will just be false.
Yeah.
So even if we were to give Socrates the assumption that the,
the,
the thesis that the soul existed before we were put together before we were
born,
it's still wouldn't follow that the soul will continue to exist afterwards that
have taken back apart.
The soul might eventually decay,
just like the engine will eventually decay.
What we need to really become convinced of the immortality of the soul is not
the mere suggestion.
Even if it was even if we were convinced,
is not the mere suggestion.
The soul was around before our birth.
We need to believe that the soul,
unlike an engine,
can itself be destroyed,
can't itself decompose,
can't fall apart.
That's what we need if we're really going to become convinced and the
immortality of the soul.
Yeah.
Now as every mark previously,
one of the amazing things and that not amazing.
So what are the really attractive things about Plato's dialogues is you raise an
objection and it often seems as though Plato himself,
whether or not he explicitly states the objection seems aware of the objection
because he'll go on to say something that is responsive to it.
And again,
that makes sense.
If you think of these dialogues is a kind of pedagogical tool to help you get
better at philosophizing.
So the very next argument that Plato turns to can be viewed,
I think as responding to this unstated objection,
why stated it?
But Plato doesn't state it.
And the dialogue,
the worry that even if the soul was one of the parts,
even if the soul was already around before we're born,
how do we know it can't come apart?
How do we know the soul cannot be destroyed since what we want to know is
whether the soul is immortal.
How do we know it can't break?
Plato's next argument then tries to deal directly with this worry and it's a
quite interesting argument.
I'll give it another,
a new label,
I'll call it the argument from simplicity.
Okay.
Socrates turns to a discussion of what kinds of things can break and what kinds
of things can't break,
what kinds of things can be destroyed and what kinds of things can't be
destroyed.
He,
he thinks about examples,
he surveys examples and tries to extract a kind of metaphysical principle from
this and then as we'll see,
he's going to use this principle to convince us or to try to convince us that
the soul is immortal.
Indestructable well,
lots of things can be destroyed.
Here's a piece of paper.
It can be destroyed.
Why was it that this was a sort of thing that could be destroyed?
Well,
the straightforward answer is the piece of paper had parts and and in breaking
it and repeat it when I literally did was I ripped one part from another to
destroy the piece of paper.
I take it parts apart.
Okay,
it's piece of chalk.
The piece of chalk can broken.
What am I doing?
Taking its parts apart?
The kinds of things that can be destroyed,
have parts,
they are composite,
they are composed of their parts.
Bodies can be destroyed because you can take a sword to it and go,
you know,
sweep,
sweep and chop it into pieces.
Okay.
Composite things can be destroyed.
Things that have parts can be destroyed.
Now what kinds of things can't be destroyed?
Well,
it won't surprise you that when Plato looks for an example of something that's
eternal and indestructable,
his mind immediately starts thinking about the platonic forms.
Take the number three,
the number three can't be destroyed.
Even if nuclear explosion took place and everything on earth got atomized and
destroyed through some,
you know,
bizarre science fiction chain reaction.
If they're always doing and movies,
the number three wouldn't be touched.
The number three wouldn't be phased.
It would still be true that three plus one equals four yet can't hurt the number
three.
Right?
You can't alter or destroy perfect circularity.
Why not?
Well,
doesn't have any parts.
That's the,
that's the thought.
Things like the platonic form are eternal and their eternal changeless
indestructable because they are simple,
simple here being the metaphysical notion that they're not composed of anything.
Anything that's built up out of parts,
you could at least in principle worry about the parts coming apart and hence the
thing being destroyed.
But anything that's simple can't be destroyed in that way,
has no parts to take apart.
So the kinds of things that can be destroyed are the things with parts and those
are the sorts of things that change,
right?
Even if they're not destroyed,
sort of.
What's a,
what's a tip off to something being composite?
The fact that it changes.
Suppose I take,
uh,
a bar of metal and I bended,
I haven't destroyed it,
but I've changed it.
I'm able to change it by rearranging the relationships between the various
parts.
My body is constantly changing because the relationships between my arms and my
head and so forth.
You know my,
my muscles are moving you,
the parts,
the thing changes all,
but that means it's got parts and could be destroyed.
So we've got some nice generalizations.
Things that change have parts,
things with parts can be destroyed.
What are the kinds of things that you can change and destroy those and the
familiar empirical objects that we can see,
pieces of paper bodies,
pieces of chalk,
bars of metal.
In contrast on the whole other side,
you've got
things that are invisible like the number three.
Nobody sees the number three things that are invisible that never changed.
And number three never changes,
right?
The number three is an odd number.
It's not as though,
oh,
today it's odd,
but maybe tomorrow it will be even.
It's eternally an odd number.
Three plus one equals four today,
yesterday and forever.
These facts about the number three will never change.
The number three is lists.
So the forms are eternal,
they're invisible,
they are changeless.
There are simple and simple things can't be destroyed.
Forms can't be destroyed.
You put all this together,
these are the sorts of thoughts that Socrates assembles,
and I've got the initial thoughts up there on the board.
All right,
so premise number one,
only composite things can be destroyed.
Premise number two,
only changing things are composite.
So if you put one and two together,
you'd get only changing.
Things could be destroyed.
But now add three invisible things don't change.
Well,
if he got to be the kind of thing that can change in order to be composite,
you gotta be composite in order to be destroyed.
Invisible things don't.
Change,
follows for invisible things can't be destroyed.
That's the metaphysical thesis that Socrates comes to by thinking about cases.
And that's the crucial premise or sub conclusion for the immortality of the
soul.
Because then Socrates invites us to think about the soul is the sole visible or
invisible?
He says pretty obviously it's
invisible,
but if invisible things can't be destroyed,
the soul cannot be destroyed.
So one,
two and three got us.
For invisible things can be destroyed,
but five,
the souls and visible,
so six,
the soul cannot be destroyed.
That's my best attempt at reconstructing.
The argument from simplicity.
It's not as though Plato himself spells it out with premises and conclusions
like that.
But I think this is fairly faithful to the kind of argument he means to put
forward.
And in a moment I'll turn to evaluating whether that's a good argument or not.
But I think it's a pretty interesting argument.
It's an argument worth taking fairly seriously.
Except I gotta confess to you that Socrates doesn't quite conclude the way I
would've thought he would've concluded.
So I've had the,
the argument conclude six,
the soul cannot be destroyed.
But what Socrates actually says is his actual conclusion is,
and so the soul is indestructable or nearly.
So that's why they're an odd qualification or nearly.
So
the conclusion that Socrates reaches from his examination of change and,
and visibility and so forth and so on.
And composite newness versus simplicity,
is it the soul's indestructable or nearly.
So now adding that qualification opens the door to a worry.
The worry gets raised by CBS who says,
even if we grant that the soul is nearly indestructible,
that's not good enough to get us in mortality.
And he gives a very nice analogy of,
of uh,
somebody who's a coat,
a which could outlast the owner but isn't immortal.
Or the owner could go through several coats,
but still at some point the owner is going to die as well.
The owner is far more immortal,
you know,
in that sense,
closer to immortality and I've got too many coats in my life,
but for all that I'm not indestructable if all we've got is the mere fact that
the sole is nearly indestructible,
it takes a whole lot more work to destroy it.
Maybe it lasts a whole lot longer.
Maybe it goes through a whole lot of bodies being reincarnated a half dozen or a
dozen or a hundred times before it wears out and gets destroyed.
That's not enough to give us the immortality of the soul.
That's the objection that CBS raises.
And one of the oddities is that as far as I can see,
Socrates never responds to that objection.
Raises the objection that is played,
oh,
raises the objection in the voice of CBS.
But Socrates,
I'm Plato's behalf never answers the objection.
It's hard to say what exactly is going on.
It might be that Plato's worried that he hasn't really shown that the soul is
immortal afterwards.
Maybe this argument from simplicity isn't really as good as it needs to be and
maybe that explains why Plato then goes on to offer yet another argument after
all of this argument really did show the immortality of the soul.
Why would he need to offer a further argument?
The argument from essential properties,
which will be turned into later,
so maybe Plato just thought there wasn't a good answer to CBS objection,
but I want to say I'm Plato's behalf or on behalf of the argument.
Socrates should never have concluded the argument with this odd qualifying
phrase that the soul is indestructible or nearly so he should have just said the
soul is indestructable full stop.
After all.
If we have premises one,
two,
and three only composite things can be destroyed.
Only changing things are composite.
Invisible things don't change.
If you put those together,
you get for invisible things can't be destroyed.
You don't get the more modest conclusion.
Invisible things can't be destroyed or it's a whole lot harder to destroy them.
If we've got one,
two,
and three,
we're entitled to the bold conclusion.
Invisible things can't be destroyed,
period.
Full Stop.
And then if five is truth,
the soul really is invisible.
We're entitled to conclude six.
The soul cannot be destroyed,
not the soul cannot be destroyed or if it can be destroyed,
it's very,
very hard and takes a very,
very long time.
We are rather entitled to the Boulder Conclusion.
This soul cannot be destroyed.
Full stop period.
End of the discussion.
Yeah.
So despite the fact that Socrates draws this weaker conclusion,
it seems to me that the argument he's offered us,
if it works at all,
entitles us to draw the boulder conclusion.
Not that the souls indestructable or nearly so,
but that their soul is indestructable.
Well,
maybe play it or realize that maybe that's the reason why he doesn't bother
giving an answer to CBS.
Maybe it's an invitation to the reader to recognize that there's a better
argument here.
Then even the characters in the drama have noticed.
Don't know.
Yeah.
Don't know what Plato had in mind,
but in any rate,
all question shouldn't be what was Plato thinking but as the argument,
any good?
Okay?
Do we now have an argument for the in mortality this all have after off,
the soul cannot be destroyed.
It's a mortal.
Is it a good argument or not?
Sinneas raises a different objection.
Symia says,
we can't conclude that the soul is indestructible or nearly soul or whatever
because we should not believe the sub conclusion for invisible things can't be
destroyed.
Sibelius says
invisible things can be destroyed and if that's true,
then of course we no longer have an argument for the indestructibility or near
indestructibility of the soul because even if the soul is invisible,
five if nonetheless,
contrary to what Socrates was claiming,
invisible things can be destroyed,
then maybe the invisible soul can be destroyed as well.
Now Sydney has does it merely assert ball,
glean visible things can be destroyed.
He offers an example of an invisible thing that can be destroyed.
Harmony
starts talking about the harmony that gets produced by a stringed instrument.
Let's say a harp
back.
He says,
this is a very nice example for us to think about because some people have
suggested,
Symia says,
some people have suggested that the mind is like harmony.
It's as though the mind is like harmony of the body.
So to sort of spell out the analogy a bit more fully,
and I'll say a bit more about it later,
harmony is to the harp as the mind is to the body.
All right?
He says that people who put forward views like this,
okay.
And at any rate,
harmony can certainly be destroyed.
You,
you don't see harmony.
Harmony is invisible.
But for all that you can destroy harmony.
You know,
so there's the harp making its melodious,
harmani harmonious sounds,
and then you take an ax to the harp,
Bang,
chop,
chop or a hammer or whatever.
Now the harmony has been destroyed.
So even though it's invisible,
you can destroy it by destroying the musical instrument on which it depends.
And of course there was the worry,
right?
If the,
if the mind is like the harmony of the body,
then you,
you could destroy the mind,
the soul by destroying the body on which the mind depends.
Okay.
So the crucial point right now is that thinking about harmony is offered as a
counter example to the generalization that invisible things can't be destroyed.
Harmonies,
invisible harmony can be destroyed.
So invisible things can be destroyed.
So you're wrong.
Socrates,
when you say invisible,
things can't be destroyed.
So even if we grant the souls and visible as well,
maybe the soul also is an invisible thing that can be destroyed.
That's a great objection.
It's an objection worth taking very seriously.
And the oddity is Socrates doesn't respond to it in the way that he should have
in the way that he needed to.
Socrates instead spends some time,
Maureen,
about the question,
is the soul really like harmony or not?
Is this metaphor think about the relationship between the mind and the body as
similar to the relationship between harmony and a harp.
Yeah,
Socrates.
Spend some time criticizing that analogy.
Now.
If in a few minutes I'll turn to you and a few minutes I'll turn to the
question.
What about Socrates criticisms of the analogy?
Are they good criticisms or not?
Yeah,
but even if they are good criticisms,
I want to say that's not good enough to help your argument.
Socrates,
even if we were to say,
you know what the mind is it very much like harmony at all.
That analogy really stinks.
So what all that sinneas needs to cause problems for Socrates argument is the
claim that harmony is invisible and harmony can be destroyed.
As long as that is true,
we can't continue to believe that invisible things can't be destroyed.
Okay?
So what Socrates means to do is to say either harmony can't be destroyed,
but pretty obviously a can.
The heart,
you know,
the melodia sounds coming out of an instrument can be destroyed.
So he would need to argue then perhaps that harmony is not really invisible.
If he could show us,
if he could convince us that harmony's not really invisible,
then we would no longer have a counterexample to the claim that the invisible
cannot be destroyed.
And the argument could still then proceed as it was before,
so that's what Socrates should have done.
He should have said,
you know what,
harmony's not really invisible or can't be destroyed,
but there's not a whiff of that,
at least in the dialogue as we've got it.
Not a width of that.
As far as I can see.
Socrates never says send me as here's where your objection goes wrong.
Harmony's not really invisible.
Can't really be destroyed,
whatever it is,
so we don't really have a counter example and said he gets hung up on this
question.
Is it a good analogy?
Is it a good way for thinking about the mind or not?
But even if it isn't,
that wouldn't save the argument.
Now I am going to take some time to think about whether or not harmony is a good
analogy
because I actually think it is a good analogy.
I think what's going on in the harmony,
you the suggestion that we should think about the mind like harmony as low as
the harmony,
the body isn't Uli attempt to to state the physical list view.
Talk about the mind says the physicalist is just a way of talking about the body
or more carefully.
It's a way about talking about certain things the body can do when it's
functioning properly.
When it's well tuned as we might put it,
just like talk about the harmony or the melodious sounds or what have you of the
harp are a way of is it these things are a way of talking about what things the
harp can do.
It can produce melodious harmonious sounds when it's functioning properly.
When it's well tuned.
So the,
the harmony analogy is I think an attempt and not a bad attempt at gesturing
towards the question.
How do physical lists think about the mind now when I tried to get you to grasp
how physical is,
think about the mind.
Yeah.
I use examples about computers and robots and the like.
Well it's not remotely surprising that Plato doesn't use those kinds of
analogies.
It doesn't have computers.
He doesn't have robots still.
He has physical objects that can do things and the ability to do things on the
proper functioning of the physical object.
And so I think he can see that there's this alternative to his dualism.
He could see that you could be a physical list and say that the mind is
dependent on the body.
The mind is just a way of talking about what the body can do when it's working
properly.
It's dependent on just the same way that,
well,
for example,
harmony is dependent upon the physical instrument.
So I think it's a very nice attempt to discuss the physicalist alternative to
Plato's dualism and that's why it'll be worth taking some time to ask ourselves,
well,
what about Plato's objections?
Then if he can convince us at the soul's not like harmony of the body,
maybe there'll be some sort of problem for the physical list.
So I'll come back to that in a few more minutes,
but first let's worry about the point that I was emphasizing earlier.
Namely,
look,
even if the soul's not very much like harmony.
So what if harmony really is invisible and harmony really can be destroyed?
Then invisible things can be destroyed.
Okay.
Even just holds nothing like you know,
that's not good analogy for thinking about the physical is positioned what have
you.
So what if some invisible things can be destroyed and harmonies and example of
that,
then by Golly it's going to follow that.
We can't conclude from the visibility of the soul that the soul cannot be
destroyed.
So even though Socrates doesn't respond to that objection,
we need to ask on Socrates behalf,
is there a possible answer to this objection.
And I think there's at least the beginnings of one
we have to ask,
when we say invisible things can't be destroyed.
What did we mean by invisible?
Okay.
And I want to distinguish three different possible interpretations.
Three different claims.
So invisible means,
okay,
one,
there's one possibility.
Can't be seen.
Two different possibility
can't be observed.
I've gotten mine the broader notion of all five senses.
Census,
three different possible interpretation of invisible can't be detected.
Okay,
well we have to ask ourselves is when Socrates pitches argument forward,
which of these did you have in mind?
First,
let's be clear on how these things are different.
All right?
Some things can't be seen but can be sensed some other way.
So
colors can be seen,
smells cannot be seen,
but of course smells.
You know,
the smell of coffee can be sensed through the five senses.
Okay.
Sounds can't be seen.
They're not visible,
but for all that they can be synced.
You can hear them through your ears.
So
without getting hung up on,
what is the English word invisible mean?
Let's just notice that there's a difference between saying,
can't be seen through the eyes and can't be observed
through one sense or the other.
And then three is a different notion altogether.
A stronger notion altogether.
There might be things that can't even be detected through any of the five
senses.
The number three,
not only,
can't I see it,
I can't taste it,
I can't hear it,
can't smell it,
can't touch it.
Right?
The number three is invisible in this much bolder way.
It can't be detected at all by the five senses.
Okay.
Can't be detected in terms of its,
it doesn't leave traces behind.
Right.
I don't see dinosaurs,
but of course they leave traces behind and fossils,
there's a way in which you can talk about it's being detected by its effects.
Right?
All right,
so again,
don't get hung up on what does the English word invisible mean?
Let's just ask ourselves what notion of invisibility,
if we'll use the word,
you know,
between these three ways.
What notion did Socrates argument turn on?
Okay,
well,
the most natural way to start by interpreting him is with number one.
Okay?
When he says invisible things don't change.
What he means is things that you can't see don't change.
And so continuing to interpret invisible,
and number four,
in the same way it visible,
things can't be destroyed on that first interpretation.
What he'd be saying is if you can't see it with your eyes,
it can't be destroyed.
Have trouble is harmony shows that that's not so harmony is indeed invisible.
Incense,
number one,
you cannot see it with your eyes,
but for all that,
it can be destroyed.
So if what Socrates means by invisibility,
visibility is the first notion.
Can't be seen with your eyes and the arguments,
not any good harmony is a pretty compelling counterexample,
but maybe that's not what Socrates means by invisible,
maybe instead of one.
He means too,
when he talks about the soul being invisible and invisible things being
indestructable,
maybe he means things that can't be observed through any of your five senses.
Okay.
Now in point of fact,
I think that is what he meant.
Okay.
We just give a quick quote.
In our edition,
this is a page 29
some of you may have noticed that there is little standardized paginations in
our edition as well,
so it's in the academy paginations number 79
okay.
He's talking about the difference between the visible and the invisible things,
chairs versus the forms and he says these ladder chairs,
trees,
stones.
You could touch and see and perceive with the other senses,
but those that always remained the same.
The forms can only be grasped by the reasoning power of the mind.
They are not seen but are invisible.
So I think it's pretty clear that when Socrates starts talking about what's
visible versus invisible,
he doesn't mean to limit himself to vision.
He means to be talking about all of the five senses,
okay?
So when we say,
when he says invisible things can't be destroyed,
he means the things that you can't see or touch or hear or feel,
right?
Whatever it is,
see,
touch,
smell,
taste.
Those things can't be destroyed.
Now notice that if that's the way we interpret his argument,
harmony no longer works.
As a counter example,
harmony was invisible when we met.
Definition number one can't be seen,
but it's not invisible.
If we mean definition number two can't be synced,
can't be observed.
Harmony can be sensed through the years,
in which case it's not a counter example.
It's not a counter.
Example to four four says invisible things can't be destroyed.
And what Socrates should have said is harmony is not invisible in the relevant
sense of invisible,
okay?
Since it can be sensed Bot,
and this would be the crucial point.
Notice,
Socrates should have continued.
The soul is invisible in that sense.
You don't see the soul,
you don't taste the soul,
you don't touch the soul,
you don't hear the soul.
So if we understand the argument in terms of the second interpretation,
it looks as other invisible.
It looks as all the arguments still goes through sim.
He says,
conjure example fails.
Harmony's not invisible in the relevant sense.
So it could still be true that invisible things can't be destroyed since the
soul is invisible in that sense,
it would fall at the soul cannot be destroyed.
However,
even if sinneas is objection,
his particular counter example,
harmony fails,
that doesn't mean that we should still accept the argument because there might
be a different counter example.
So here's my proposal.
Supposedly think not about harmony,
but radio waves.
Okay?
Radio waves are not sense a bowl.
They are not observable.
You don't see a radio wave,
you can't touch a radio wave,
you can't smell a radio wave.
And interesting enough,
you can't hear radio waves.
Okay?
But of course for all that,
they can be destroyed.
So even if we grant that what Socrates meant by invisible was cannot be
observed.
We still have to say with Sydney,
you know,
force,
just not true.
Some invisible things can be destroyed.
Radio waves can be destroyed even though they're invisible in the relevant
sense.
Yeah.
Question.
Perfect radio waves.
Okay,
so the suggestion was radio waves are a bit like the forms.
They're not forums,
but they're perfect in that way.
Was that the thought?
They made those,
Oh,
okay.
I misunderstood.
The question is rather look,
radio waves are not like forms
to which the answer is yes,
that's exactly the problem.
They are invisible like the forms,
but unlike the forms they're destructible and that's precisely why we've got to
worry about the soul.
Is the sole invisible in the way the forms are being indestructable or is it
invisible in the way that radio waves are distractible?
And again,
my point here is not to say,
oh you idiot played or why didn't you think of radio waves?
Are Questions not,
you know,
was Plato overlooking something he should have thought of?
It's does this argument work or not?
Is it true that the invisible things can't be destroyed?
And it seems to me that some things that are invisible in the relevant sense,
radio waves being an example of that can be destroyed.
So even though the soul is also invisible in the relevant sense,
maybe it can be destroyed as well.
Now the answer it seems to me the only answer I can imagine,
Socrates or played or giving at this point is to say,
look,
I need a different definition of invisible,
not two,
but three.
Don't talk about what we can sense.
Talk about what we can detect.
Okay.
Radio waves can be detected right after all radios do that.
You turn on your radio,
radio waves passing by.
Boom,
properly tuned you detect it turns it into any sounds that we can here.
Okay.
We can detect radio waves on the basis of their effects on radios,
among other things,
so maybe by invisible he should have moved to this stronger,
bolder definition of invisible,
let's call something invisible.
Not only if it can't be seen,
not only if it can't be observed,
but if it can't be detected at all.
The forms after all can't be detected.
There's no,
there's no radio for the number three that will tell you there's no,
there is no Geiger counter and to tell you the number threes nearby or
something.
Right?
So Plato could still insist.
Things that are invisible in the sense of in undetectable can't be destroyed,
but radio waves,
they're detectable so they're not a counterexample.
Now that we interpret the relevant notion of invisibility is undetectable,
so couldn't play Doh continue to claim things that are fully invisible,
meaning undetectable.
Those things can't be destroyed.
Radio waves under counter example of that,
I think maybe plateau could say that,
but if we give him four where we've read invisible as meaning,
honorly undetectable no longer were so clear to me that we can give him five is
the sole invisible?
Well,
it was when we're buying visibility mean we meant can't be seen.
It was when by in visibility we meant can't be tasted or touched or heard or
smelled.
But is it still invisible if by in visibility we mean can't be detected?
Is it true that the soul can't be detected?
I've got to say,
I think it's no longer right.
Once we interpreted visibility that way,
the sole is detectable in just the way on that,
literally just the way,
but it's something similar to the way that radio waves are detectable.
If you hook a radio wave up with a radio,
you can tell the radio is where the radio wave was there because of what the
radio's doing.
Giving off these sounds,
if you hook a soul up to our body,
you can tell the soul is there by what the salt,
by what the body's doing,
discussing philosophy with you.
You detect the presence of your friends soul through its affects on your
friend's body,
but that means the soul isn't really undetectable,
but if the soul is not really undetectable,
it's not really invisible in the relevant sense,
and if it's not really invisible,
then even if there is our notion of invisible such that things that are
invisible in that sense can't be destroyed souls not invisible in that sense.
I've gone over this argument at such length because I hope it's clear.
I think it's a pretty interesting argument.
The argument from simplicity is quite fascinating.
The idea that you couldn't break the soul if it didn't have parts.
And the way to tell that doesn't have parts is because it's invisible because
they're miserable.
Things can have parts.
That's a quite difficult argument to pin down.
Does it work or does it not work?
But I think as we think it all through,
we have to conclude it doesn't work.
Okay.